[Musique]
il est pascal est né en 1956 à sidi bel
abbès six ans après c'est par enseignant
s'installe dans la région de saint malo
ou lycées de cette ville en 72 philly
pour rencontre le guitariste gilles
onzia et découvre avec lui lou reed et
le velvet underground
en 1977 phillip et instituteurs et
accepte d'être le chanteur du groupe
rennais marquis de sade
un an après philippe pascal kit
l'éducation nationale et se présente en
1979 avec marquis de sade au festival du
midem à cannes
la grande presse découvre alors avec ce
groupe la new wave
c'est le début pour marquis de sade une
notoriété qui devient les gens dans la
fin 80 quand le groupe décide de se
séparer pour philippe se sont ensuite
deux ans de réflexion de silence
jusqu'au retour sur scène en avril 83
avec son nouveau groupe
marc burg voilà une carrière donc déjà
riche de 3 45 tours et de trois albums
au lieu d'être aujourd'hui
tranquillement instituteur dans un petit
village philippe vous vous exposez
depuis six ans sur la scène du rock aux
critiques à l'enthousiasmé ou regret du
public avec en plus toutes les
difficultés matérielles des artistes est
ce que vous n'avez jamais regretté ce
choix dans votre vie pas vraiment non tu
sais vous savez si on n'a pas faim si on
sait exactement de quoi demain sera fait
j'ai pas l'impression qu'on vive
réellement enfin pour mon compte j'ai
besoin d'incertitude un jour à 20 ans je
me suis trouvée prématurément vieilli
j'ai l'impression que ma vie était toute
tracée
et donc je sais c'est l'éducation
nationale en trois ans d'existence
marquis de sade a bouleversé les données
du rock en france et toutes les
conséquences que cela peut avoir sur le
comportement du public même sur la mode
et comment expliquez vous aujourd'hui ce
phénomène marquis de sade avec six ans
de recul je crois qu'on a été le premier
groupe français à s'occuper de musique
ce n'était plus des textes mis en
musique
c'était un travail sur la forme et les
sur la musique alors que la majorité des
groupes français encore maintenant
s'occupe uniquement de parole et d'un
vague accompagnement et je pensais
téléphone starshooter trust en fait
c'est le texte qui qui prédomine
alors que ce n'était pas le cas du tout
dans marquis de sade que jean
rendez-vous maintenant dans ces verbes
l'émotion de la vie semble avoir
beaucoup d'importance comme dans jour
après jour dans ton cas voir un extrait
c'est qu'est ce que vous voulez passer
comme message qui met s'agit à travers
vos textes
au risque de vous décevoir je ne sais
pas du tout ce que j'essaie de faire
passer et quand même look ne lis pas du
tout le travail qu'il fait on fait ce
qui nous place par le dans la tête on
est très instinctif
on espère on essaye de faire une musique
un peu aventureuse expérimenter les tas
de choses mais je sais pas non parce que
je vais passer
on parle beaucoup des références de
philippe pascal à la période de
l'entre-deux-guerres allemand est ce
qu'il ya une similitude entre les années
80 et les années 20 et 30 allemand j'ai
pas vraiment l'impression non j'aimerais
beaucoup j'aimerais beaucoup mais j'ai
l'impression que l'angoissé espèce
d'angoissé métaphysique qui pour moi est
un support pour tout le monde et nous
vers de la création qu'ont ressenti
toute une génération après la guerre de
de 14-18 on la retrouve plus du tout
maintenant on est tellement drogués par
la télévision par la radio des chaînes
hi fi
il n'y a plus de révolte il ya plus
d'incertitudes comme on parlait comme en
ont parlé au début du journal
[Musique]